[Music]
go to kuala lude app inshallah the app
tracks versus pages and time spent
reading and the verses to pages function
takes you from reading a few verses a
day to a few pages a day this project is
for the real enthusiasts if there's
enough of us out there this will become
the future of quran apps and support the
project if you can inshaallah may allah
bless all of you
how are you guys doing now many of you
will be aware
many of you will be aware of the back
and forth i've had with one douglas
murray now for you who don't know this
man is a british journalist but he has
been given a platform by the likes of
the bbc the spectator he has been part
of the
neoconservative movement in britain and
in the west and has been a voice against
uh i would say islam and muslims for
some time a critic of islam and muslims
for some time in fact let me read
something to you
to give you a flavor of what this man is
all about he says conditions for muslims
in europe must be made harder across the
board he says europe must look like
a less attractive proposition
from long before we were first attacked
it should have been made plain that
people who come into europe are here
under our rules and not theirs
he says where a mosque has become a
center of hate it should be closed and
pulled down if that means that some
muslims don't have a mosque to go to
then they'll have to realize that they
aren't owed one now the first part of
that sentence
that conditions for muslims in europe
must be made harder across the board
it's
so
anti-western ideology
anti-enlightenment ideology if we're
talking about equality if we're talking
minority rights all of these things it
goes against those
things now i'm not asking douglas murray
to become a muslim i mean we invite all
of the world to islam to the worship of
one god of course and that it does
include douglas murray but what i would
for now at least like to see is douglas
murray being
self-consistent with his own principles
because this is a man who i
i'm going to have to say as it is
is nothing but a hypocrite he is a
hypocrite
he makes himself out to be some kind of
a bastion
for freedom of speech and expression but
he's a co-founder of
an organization called the henry jackson
organization
he's the co-founder of an organization
that produces reports on a yearly basis
and these reports in fact are an attempt
to
account organizations which have muslim
speakers
in universities and he states or not him
but the report states for example
extremist hate preachers have
near unfettered access to students
and by that of course he means with his
understanding of
extremism
anything that goes against western
ideological or enlightenment values so
you see here this is really it's
enraging it's enraging how these
individuals that speak about freedom of
speech
are attempting
to do actions words or have words and
actions
do produce reports which have the net
effect and entailment of curtailing
freedom of speech for a minority group
which is the muslims he in fact or not
him but the report states
that failure by university to apply
there's been a failure by university to
apply prevent duties now for those who
don't know or maybe live abroad prevent
is the government's counter-terrorism
strategy so here we have a situation
where the henry jackson society which is
co-founded by douglas murray is
producing these reports and these
reports aim to vilify label or otherwise
cancel
yes
muslim speakers traditionalist orthodox
speakers
from speaking in universities because
they're afraid that they have quote
unfettered access to students
students were talking about what age 18
to 21 adult students
so in this situation here
clearly murray and co
are using
the guise of terrorism to vilify a
community and to inhibit freedom of
speech
don't talk to me about freedom of speech
what kind of censoring is this
you coward you are a coward
and this is you know why it's clear to
me that you are a coward and that you
are afraid of public engagement and
debate
because when it came to me challenging
you on twitter for a discussion
when i came to challenge you on twitter
for a discussion or debate let's be
straightforward with you because we
don't see i
what did you say you made the excuses
you call me anti-semitic you call me all
these words because i'm anti-zionist
because i am pro-palestinian unashamedly
so
you will never find a statement of mine
and the whole public record which
amounts to anti-semitism but you cowered
even if i was a fully fledged
anti-semite and hated jews
which we believe in islam it's not
possible to do or you shouldn't do
because the prophet himself married the
jews i fear
you didn't know that did you and he even
he condemned anti-semitism which i have
videos on my channel doing the same
thing
but if this is your excuse why are you
discussing with anjim chowdhury
let's take a picture let's take a look
at a picture of you discussing with
anjim chowdhury
anjem chowdhury is widely recognized in
the muslim community as someone who
belongs to the radical fringes someone
who has not condemned isis not condemned
al-qaeda not condemned these groups in
many ways as sympathetic to those groups
and you have you have had a discussion
with him but you with me
what now you're getting cold feet you're
getting a bit scared
what is your excuse
that i'm not qualified
i think you'll find that i'm much more
qualified on these topics than you are
especially islam what are your
qualifications in islam
what are your qualifications in islam
what is your training in islam
what background you've written two books
to my knowledge about islam but what is
your qualification to speak about such a
topic like theology
huh tell me now
you come to me humbly as a student
that's the only relationship you can
have with me when it comes to the
religion of islam you come to me humbly
cross-legged
as a student in front of me and i will
tell you about islam the rulings the
books that i've memorized the language
that i know
the years that i've spent in the islamic
seminary and the degrees that i've
acquired you're not in my league on
these issues don't even pretend to be
and how dare you try and attack the
quran and say the book the measly
pathetic little book that you have
produced
apparently he says it's uh it's more
bought than the quran
it's it's
people are buying it more than the quran
are you that
sorry mentally
slow
do you think people buy the quran on
amazon
this is the tweet he put up you can
check it on the twitter this guy he
thinks that his book is being read by
muslims or by other people as much and
or
maybe the same amount as the quran are
you a fool are you literally a fool
this book is being one of the most
memorized no it is the most memorized
book in the world
children memorize it and you're talking
about your measly little book that you
put on amazon
anyway let's move on to something else
let's move on to what you actually say
about islam let me expose your ignorance
further because it's not just islam and
theology that you have a uh inhibition
you have a weakness in but you have an
inhibition and you have a weakness when
it relates to the humanities in your
book
uh the strange death of europe you refer
to as conjuring a careful new version of
history which flies in the face of all
historical scholarships practically all
historical scholarship we're not saying
that the whole time in spain was good
you had the al-wahidu
but to try and uh
imply
that there was intolerance throughout
the whole time period when islam was in
spain is foolishness and a historical
understanding
on anyone's understanding
and you you make blunders historical
blunders you say
europe was never
a continent of islam what are you
talking about
we have europe as you have spain as the
example you have sicily as another
example and you have other places which
the ottoman empire had control over as
other examples as well are you that
are you literally that foolish
are you literally that foolish why are
you speaking about things which you have
no idea about
on this point let's take a look at what
you've said about islam let's say islam
is a very very complex thing
and the best way i can do this in the
very short time i have is that you have
three islams islam one two and three
islam one the quran and the life of
muhammad and the hadith islam to the
tradition of the sharia islam three what
muslims do now the first of those things
islam the quran and so on is bad
it is bad
there is a lot of violence in it and
what's worse the peaceful verses are
superseded by the violent verses
the violent verses also sadly are more
numerous in number then you've got the
life of muhammad again a bad man a very
bad man it has to be not a great role
model if you look at it uh it takes
child brides abuses a small girl
multiple wives uh himself a warrior
himself a war criminal himself beheads
uh
jews
this i would have thought would be a
signal of not great peacefulness so he
makes a series of as you saw with that
clip here
this
man
makes a series of claims about islam and
this is the video he sent me by the way
on twitter he said this is why i speak
about islam as if to shobot to
grandstand to show me something i didn't
know
and this is what you have to present
blunder after blunder of the blunder
let's go over each one of them he said
the quran is bad that's an assertion and
this is a static aesthetic value
judgment and it's not based on evidence
so i will not even um dignify that with
a response he states the peaceful verses
are superseded by the violent ones
that's not true in its entirety in fact
that's not true at all you have verses
like chapter 60 verse 8.
60 verse 8 that allah does not forbid
you to be good with those non-muslims
who have not tried to kill you and not
try to kick you out of your homes that
you be good with them and you be just
with them because allah he loves the
just
that's not abrogated and it's not
superseded by any verse is it peaceful
yes or no you answer me my questions
since you're the one making the claims
yeah you answer my questions now because
imagine if you are right in front of me
you're talking about my body he was
trying to body shame me the guy was
trying to talk about my body this
you're trying to talk about me and even
your followers were saying actually
you know i think you know
anyways i'm not going to say anything
but you can go and see on twitter what
his followers were saying
what your boyfriend maybe have been
saying and other people
but anyway the first thing you say is
that the the verses of the quran
are superseded the peaceful ones yeah
so is this a peaceful verse or not
chapter 60 verse 8
answer me the question
what about chapter 4 verse 90
except for the ones
that they come to you and there's a
peace treaty between you uh you too or
that you and all that they've come with
peace
this is not abrogated this verse is not
abrogated
fight those who fight you and do not go
across the bounds do not transgress the
bounds because allah does not like those
who transgress the bounds
is that superseded is that abrogated
this is my these are my questions i mean
you tell me if you
when the prophet muhammad said
that whoever kills a non-combatant
non-believer will not smell the
fragrance of heaven has that been
abrogated my question is
the answer is no the prophet told us
which you won't find in jewish or judah
christian tradition very clear
if you if you go to war do not kill the
old person the woman the chil the child
mckenna alejandr
he said about a woman it's not for this
woman it's a woman dead in the
battlefield it's not for her to be
killed
he reiterated the same commands so these
are just
old orientalist tropes misconceptions
which unfortunately because you have
been reading bernard lewis and ibn raqqa
who is not a school you mentioned he's a
scholar he's not a scholar but lewis is
a historian what's he got to do with
theology of islam
so you don't even know how to quote
proper authorities on these points
yeah
because you've been reading these people
you don't know how to nuance the
discussion you have become ignorant you
are ignorant you don't know how to
access primary source material you don't
know how to be honest with the sources
and when you try your best you fail
look you've just stated two sentences
about islam and the only thing that i
see you speaking about the religion
directly and you've already made two
mistakes
let's go on though
you say that
there are more basically the violent
verses
are more numerous than the the peaceful
ones there's
6236 verses of the quran
now i don't know
have you read the the translation of the
meanings of the quran because if you
have it's impossible to come to that
conclusion
it is impossible to come to that
conclusion are you telling me of a ratio
that the violent verses are more than
the non-violent verses in the quran then
you've you maybe have been reading the
art of war not the quran
you've been reading another book
this is a foolish statement that no one
who has read the quran even the
translations of the meanings of would
ever make you you're ignorant how dare
you even think that you can debate me
you can speak to me you're not qualified
you're not you're not even that popular
to be honest let's be honest who are you
anyway who are you to try and step up
like this who are you
of all you respect and you come and talk
about islam you talk about muslims need
to be treated
in this way and that way in the other
way
that they are ticking time bombs that's
another quote of his by the way they're
a demographic ticking time bomb
well i'll tell you what we're an
intellectual you're an intellectual
ticking time bomb because now you're
starting to implode upon yourself
you are starting to implode upon
yourself and you're continuing to do
that now
then you say the life of muhammad he was
a bad man or another assertion did they
not teach you in gcse
that is p-e-e point evidence explanation
did they not teach you that one so you
stating muhammad was a bad man
you weak man you are a weak man you are
a weak man look at you making
an error in every statement that every
sentence that you utter towards islam
about islam you're uttering it with
erroneous statements filled with
philosophy
and totally you are an imbecile you are
an imbecile what kind of debility is
this what kind of intellectual debility
imbecility personality is this
i tell you
i think you know and i know this
wouldn't end well if we were standing
next to each other and we were having an
intellectual discussion
and that's why you scurried along didn't
you that's the real reason why you
scurried along you put
you put your tail between your legs and
you had to run away
you tried to engage me on twitter
but you wouldn't engage me face to face
and then he says he abuses a small child
or a small girl
give me the evidence of that
where's the evidence of abuse
when ah isha herself who you referred to
i isha herself
she states that the prophet he never hit
any of his wives he was never abusive to
any of his wives or his servants ana
malek himself said that he the prophet
never so much
as
uttered
vocalizations of contempt and you're
talking about abuse what's the evidence
you're historically impotent
you're incapable intellectually
incapable of producing the goods
the knowledge goods on these matters
and then he says multiple wives
what's the problem with having multiple
wives you haven't given us a moral
reason why having multiple wives is
wrong
a warrior why is that bad thing to have
a warrior prophet
being a warrior is a good thing so
you're mentioning these things
warrior and then he states he himself
beheads the jews okay i want you to give
me one evidence from the seed of the
biography of the prophet where he
beheads jewish people because they're
jewish in fact if he beheads any jewish
people at all the prophet muhammad never
beheaded the jew that never happened
you're a liar you are a liar
and if you are talking about banu
quraida the 600 jewish people that were
executed because of treachery
and even that treachery was was realized
by historians in the western academy
people like karen armstrong who are in
her book the short introduction to islam
unequivocally and unambiguously details
the main reason for such a thing
or author
being or not even ben
i should say
the combatants among them
were was because of treachery war
treachery that happened in the battle of
khandak
and if it was a matter of genocide and
disposable disposing of jewish people
then why did the prophet muhammad
sallallahu salaam do a constitution of
medina
why did he guarantee the rights of the
jewish people why did he not do the same
thing with bernoulli
why why did he marry a jew
why in the quran in chapter number 59
verse number four
it states on this issue of banuk
it gives the reason for why the
hostilities took place between the some
muslim tribes and some jewish tribes
that is because they oppose allah and
his messenger
it's not because delhi
that's because they were jewish bro with
all due respect you don't know what
you're talking about you do not know
what you're talking about yeah and so
this is the thing you can you can be a
critic of islam in your little echo
chamber but you are a coward and you are
not courageous as jordan peterson said
you were because if you were and i give
credit to you and peterson for having a
conversation with me which was kurt
which was courteous and cordial
if you were you would at least talk to
me and with whatever energy you come to
me with i'll come to you with that
energy but the energy that you've been
coming to the whole muslim community
with talking to us about taking time
bombs talking to us about unequal rights
for our community talking to us about
religion being a religion of opportunism
yeah the religion itself is an
opportunistic religion and other such
things for a man that's unqualified
untrained or otherwise
unaware
you really can't make a case for
yourself can you
so next time you utter the word islam or
next time you utter the word muslim from
your mouth well next time you or your
your institute that you found it
co-founded
produce reports remember
that it's hypocrisy that runs
through your veins
not not just blood but hypocrisy that
runs through every artery and every vein
in your body
you talk about freedom of speech
and cancer culture but you do
to the traditionalist muslims and
orthodox muslims what you claim the left
has done to you that's the reality of
the situation that is the reality of the
situation and you
you do anything
but embody either spirit or word of what
the liberal theorist said which is that
i disapprove of what you say but i
defend to the death your right to say it
you don't embody that in either spirit
or sentiment because you are a coward
and you are a hypocrite
and that is the reality of the situation
and for those who want to see
bridges being built
and you know civility
and lack of toxicity and so on i say as
the arabs say allah yeah we want that as
well the muslim community does actually
want coexistence and harmony we do but
you can't reasonably ask me
all my community
to be
an accomplice to our own murder
was
allah